LeBron who goes to the place where he
won two championships but it's always
special to go back where you've done
something with you know Muncie Mason
look towards me to go out there and beat
him to victory he's feeling it coming
back to his all teams five four three
fire your ammo
a quarter 19 points in seniority he's
unstoppable right now she's giving
bought you out the way yeah
than the building just dominating with
everything he's done LeBron is already
here south here he goes LBJ is gonna
take it off
28 points abroad continuing his rampage
right now put a lot of work into my
craft they're suing a lot of reads a lot
of mirror rains just trying to get my
timing but the Brian now has 37 points
jumper settles it let's get what he
wants he's just yet 41 now this crowd is
used to seeing that he took a seal on
his shoulders told me to finish the game
off he say go 43 I bet you won't go for
your three so I went for the three
[Applause]
I got a lot of special memories here I'm
trying to have some special memories
here to have the laser most ever scored
by a Laker against Miami
[Applause]
[Music]